now finally before we go this story I
just couldn't pass this one this from
slate which teaches us so much about our
relationships I love my boyfriend but
one a girlfriend this is what a woman is
writing him into slate he doesn't want
to open up our relationship my partner
is the most compassionate loving and
respectful partner I could ask for he
has supported me through difficult times
weight fluctuations questioning my
gender changing my name and sobriety
among other things
yikes I'm incredibly attracted to women
yeah oh man this guy so you question
your gender while you're dating this guy
he sticks with you you change your name
he sticks with you you change your
appearance a lot he sticks with you
you've battled addiction he's stuck he
sticks with you but now you say I'm
incredibly attracted to women and so you
want to sleep with other people
he knows this we've talked about opening
our relationship however he's on the
spectrum of asexuality and is only
interested in having sex with me you
might have missed it in all the jargon
that's just a term for monogamy he said
there's the spectrum of asexual
asexuality I guess means you don't want
to have sex so if you are having sex if
you do have sex sometimes
then you're not asexual you might not be
a a nymphomaniac or something but you're
not asexual this is but he's only
interested in having sex with me meaning
he's my boyfriend you didn't used to
have to explain what that term meant the
thought of me having sex with other
people makes him deeply uncomfortable as
we both relate to sex in different ways
hmm we have had this conversation a few
times in the year that we've been
together but with no solid plan or
outcome I respect and appreciate our
relationship more than my desire to
sleep around but I'm worried that I will
be missing something I'm only 20 and I
know that feelings change but he's an
incredible domestic and sexual partner
yikes man that's like a damning with
faint praise that's what you say about
you're not the love of your life
he's a very good domestic and sexual
partner yeah so and I would like to be
with him for a long time not forever not
endless love but you know for a long
time
is there a way to figure this out or
will this core incompatibility be what
breaks us apart
what's the incompatibility he wants to
date you and you want to cheat on him
that's the Union compatibility I
actually sort of feel for this girl
she's obviously very confused and she's
being encouraged in her confusion by a
very confused culture
she said she's young and we're told that
the whole whole purpose of life is to
get as much pleasure as we can that's
the only point of it and so if you're
young and you're not sleeping with a ton
of people all the time then you're
you're missing out on life because we're
told that monogamy and commitment and
marriage is bad and we should delay it
and put it off I was told this for much
of my life certainly by the popular
culture but that's kind of the culture
we're living in and we're told that you
know sleeping around and and all that
sort of stuff is really ultimately
fulfilling which if anyone's ever tried
it you find out in the end it's not
ultimately all that fulfilling is there
a way to figure this out yes here's the
way to don't sleep around simple as that
don't view your partner as an instrument
for your own pleasure view him as a
real-life human being with flesh and
blood and a soul that you are not just
taking from but that you are giving
yourself to comes down a lot to these
political questions that we're talking
about all right
we're not just we're not just here
looking at our fellow Americans and
seeing them as as sort of instruments
for our own pleasure and our own benefit
we're not just looking around at our
politics that way either we are citizens
we have first of all we're members of
families and we're members of
communities that were members of States
then we're citizens of this country we
have loyalties we have duties we have
affections the media doesn't know that
the media's totally sold out their
country another shilling for our number
one geopolitical adversary they they
have no understanding of this at all
they're willing to go to the highest
bidder whoever is gonna buy them off
like China that's what that's one
version of the world not not all that
different from the way this this chikki
is thinking about life either
but that's the wrong way it ultimately
will not be particularly gratifying you
will find much more much more
satisfaction in gratitude your your
babies are not just an instrument for
your pleasure and you shouldn't be paid
to raise your own children right you
will find much more satisfaction in a
position if used the world with some
gratitude with some humility with some
loyalty and with with you having a real
role in rather than this total
alienation willing to be bought off by
the highest bidder
[Music]
[Music]